tiana round two back again
back again good to see you thank you
too oh okay
so i mean there's so much to get into
you know there's a whole industry around
like
every week people predicting what's
going to happen next all the theories
it's very exciting for fans you must
feel that excitement too
absolutely i love reading the
predictions
and the theories and all the easter egg
things i mean sometimes y'all show me
things that i didn't need
so it's really fun it's really fun we
did really get to see that sort of
like like a three-act structure for the
show right like the first three episodes
being this way
the following three being this way are
we gonna see another huge shift
when we get into i mean starting this
coming friday what's gonna happen
as we get to the end there is a lot more
to come
there you guys need to hold on to your
seats
and get ready um because what we've
already
laid down is has been amazing and
mind-blowing
and it just keeps going
as far as the like interconnectedness
of all the stories each character's
individual arc
the larger stories for the series and
the movies are you like
is is there a whiteboard for you like
there is for jimmy when he's trying to
figure everything out
like do you have it kind of straight in
your head about where your character's
gonna go versus
what's gonna happen with carol versus
what's gonna happen with a larger marvel
universe do you know these things
absolutely not absolutely not
my whiteboard looks nothing like jimmy's
it would be
one line and then i just would give up
there it's way
complex and interconnected and i
i i have a sense just as a fan not like
a
uh inner uh hunch or anything or
not because i any of any in your uh
secret knowledge
but just as a fan watching i have an
idea of what i think is going to happen
with each
character in person but i don't really
know
anything last time we talked i told you
that
monica was my captain marvel that's the
one i grew up reading
and so we are getting to see now like
pretty
like blatant hints that we're getting to
a point where
monica's gonna we're gonna see something
from her
um does the idea of that like people
being able to react to a moment like
that
excite you
[Laughter]
um you know
um i don't know how to answer that i'm
sorry carlos i'm like
there are assumptions in there that i
can't necessarily
agree with okay yeah okay
all right the round two thing
totally fits because it is like you know
you do have to bob and weave a bit when
it comes to
you know talking about these subjects
and ask answering these questions
was there like a seminar was there a
seminar before you joined where some
people were like okay this is what
this is how you can talk about it this
is how you can talk about it they they
do send you
a a outline of hey reminder this
is what's what people know and this is
what they don't and i studied it very
hard carlos so
um you will not get me today but with
that said it is interesting because
you feel a little more free um to speak
because everybody has seen so many
episodes but still just trying to remind
myself that
there is still a lot of surprises in for
you all
and i don't want to ruin it yes
absolutely and as you have seen over the
last few weeks the fans are very excited
every time we get a surprise so that's a
good thing too
um we saw a little bit of your
of monica's sort of like bristling at
the mention
of carol captain marvel um do you think
we'll see
sort of the resolution of that or the
reason why that is sooner or later
well as you know um i was announced or
yeah i was announced to be joining the
cast of captain marvel
2 with uh brie larson's captain marvel
and um kamala khan
the kamla khan character so i do
believe that we're gonna get more into
that relationship and what's going on
with
those two
[Applause]
[Laughter]
well i'm listen i'm looking forward to
it
a lot of people are thank you i'm so
happy that you all
are well thanks thanks for this time
it's a pleasure whenever we get a chance
to do this
um i'm looking forward to the next time
thank you carlos thank you so much
all right take care